new the latest numbers from the UK we
had the numbers from the nation's we
were waiting for that whole UK figure
which because of the way they are
calculated tends to differ slightly so
UK hospital death toll from coronavirus
has risen by 861 to 13,000 729 up from
12,000 868 the day before so rise of 861
on the previous day let speak to skies
total Spencer to look at that figure in
context we were told yesterday by the
chief medical officer professor Chris
witty at Katie that we were potentially
expecting a spike is that what we're
seeing here
we certainly do see an increase in
today's figures an increase in the
numbers but I would actually say reading
these figures if you look actually at
the data while while it is increasing it
isn't actually perhaps the spike that
Professor Witte was expecting us to see
today it is still a fairly low increase
they were seeing one of the significant
things that we have though from the UK
figures we now know that in terms of
confirmed cases the UK has now exceeded
a hundred thousand the number of cases
has increased by four thousand two
hundred and twenty within this 24-hour
data period collecting collecting of
data to a hundred and three thousand and
ninety three total number of deaths now
in the UK stands at thirteen thousand
seven hundred and twenty-nine an
increase of ATS 861 and just to sort of
put that in context for you comparing it
to the data that we've received
yesterday in the day to the received the
day before it isn't as sharp and
increase as perhaps we would have
thought it would be so yesterday we saw
an increase of 761 further deaths in the
UK the day before it was an increase of
778 today's data an increase of 861
deaths in the UK it isn't that
significant spike that you would expect
to get after the easter bank holiday
weekend
perhaps a positive sign I mean with
these daily figures you can't really
read too much into individual days but
certainly what is positive it is it
isn't that big spike that Professor
Witte warned us about yesterday